hey guys my name is Jess today's the
11th of May and you're watching games
what news talcolm have announced when
the next phoenix wright ace attorney
game spirit of justice is due to arrive
in the west the publisher explains the
game would be released in north america
and europe in September but will only be
available through the Nintendo eShop
it's going to cost 30 bucks in the US
and 25 pounds in the UK the game's
description reads spirit of Justice is
packed with puzzles on top of the series
is well known witty and humorous
courtroom drama divination seance joins
popular investigation techniques from
previous instalments to keep you
constantly on your toes both in and out
of the courtroom you can check out a
bunch of images and a trailer from the
game in our story on site a new report
from kotaku UK has suggested that
Microsoft rejected a number of offers
from publishers looking to buy the fable
franchise as developer lionhead studios
the report suggests letters of intent
were reportedly filed and the bias
included some of the biggest names in
video game publishing but Microsoft was
unwilling to sell the franchise which
led to the closure of line head in April
multiple sources confirmed that these
discussions took place although no
specific interested parties are listed
in the report a source close to Xbox
claimed the offers were in the range of
hundreds of millions and would have
included both the studio and the favored
franchise kotaku added buying the
franchise without the studio would have
meant publishers would have had to
create new games under a licensing
agreement with Microsoft which isn't
ideal for access has revealed that
civilization 6 will arrive on october 21
of this year in Civilization six cities
will no longer be stacked so you can
spread your settlements over multiple
tiles
and specialized them better by making
use of different terrains resources and
space director ed Beach explains we want
to stop players from falling into
patterns we want players to build their
empires differently everything we want
you to consider your military
differently we want to encourage new
approaches you'll also be able to
exploit this muses layup by attacking
the specific buildings that will gain
you the most advantage having another
layer of strategy to warfare for
everything we know so far be sure to
check out our story on gamespot let me
know down in that comment section if
you're keen to plays give six and be so
to stop by again [ __ ] where we've got
stories on bail killed one and give er
that's everything I have you today but
as always that we know what mattered to
you and I'm still dancing